[Music]
that's what I'm talking about
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
okay
two send her up
oh
foreign
[Music]
everybody
don't fall into your throat
[Music]
step two keep your mind it's a
homolateral throw
not this
boom step through
there you go
[Music]
you have to do both sides of your body
oh
there you go
[Music]
better timing
thank you
your timing though
[Music]
foreign
thanks
don't pause yourself
[Music]
I don't fall
oh I'm in there
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
from Vietnam
[Applause]
attention is there
[Music]
wow
nah oh I don't know okay
[Music]
your muscles
thank you
not like this
[Music]
connection it's like this
connect your body
disconnected
[Music]
come on
look it's tension Let It Go Let It Go
[Music]
ES
organize my body oh
this is stable organization you're
usually oh
yeah just like you don't look like this
[Music]
you organized
oh you should be organized
[Music]
oh cool
okay
your Center is not involved you can
instructors are not related to each
other you get this one
[Music]
knife
Let It Go
es
with us
[Music]
really that's the same side
as long as your life
[Music]
assistant
foreign
[Music]
thank you
it's your target hi Susie
[Music]
don't way down
don't connect your emotional self to
your fatigue
[Music]
go through your attacks
come on
extension keep training
[Music]
stage
okay
[Music]
so I remind myself how do you tell me
you breathe too much out on the Kia
[Music]
hey
what's up